A great way to build an audience
is through social networks.
Lots of games have options to link to
Facebook or Twitter and share your high
score with your friends or even invite
them to play the same game as you.
And they'll give you an incentive to
do so, like Candy Crush will give you
powerups if you can invite a new
Facebook friend to play the game.
It's like a trade.
Some games even rely on an individual
fan to spread the word, people
like YouTube stars or Tumblr users whose
reviews can reach a lot of people.
So as you build your game,
think about how you'll want to integrate
with social media and
create your own gaming community.